how David Harbor  how big is this  we just discussed absolutely like crazy  it's just one word it's two t-o-o he's  too big  it's that seriously stop stop I need it  how did  like out of the womb performing  theatrics right I was a colicky child so  I was screaming and crying so I was like  I was like fostering that but no when I  was five years old I did The Wizard of  Oz in kindergarten I played in the DM I  had one line look Henry there's a storm  coming up when you were in kindergarten  yeah when I was like eight oh my God I  played Charlie I played the Tin Man you  did yes I wanted to play Dorothy but I  didn't drop oh the first of matches I'll  show you